[Music]
welcome to on contact today we discuss
the second war on terror with a
journalist glenn greenwald what they're
doing here
is essentially running a parallel
investigation to the justice department
because they're angry that the justice
department hasn't indicted anybody on
these grandiose claims of conspiracy to
incite an insurrection or sedition or
treason or attempting to like kill or
murder or kidnap aoc
and what they're really trying to do is
just to feed
this
hungry liberal mob with the spectacle of
dragging
mostly poor and impoverished and
lawyerless people before them to just
kind of publicly vilify them
as a supplement to the prosecution
that the doj is already
pursuing in the
the case law that has limited and
prescribed the ability of congress to
investigate warrentown dangerous it is
when they exceed that unsurprisingly
comes from the mccarthy era when
congress did the same thing
you